and I'm gonna go out on let me or give
my prediction I think it's been a close
fight I think there's gonna be some
controversy I think Mark Chev is going
to take him down a lot of people well
way more uh and look more into the
takedowns opposed to what volcanovsky's
doing on the feet so there's gonna be
rounds where I'm like well uh Mike Jeff
did get him down but volcanovsky's
landed more shots on the feet I think
Mark Jeff's uh gonna struggle with the
tenacity with the speed the quickness
the the sheer lack of height with uh
volkonovsky and I think volcanovski is
gonna be able to get back to his feet
frustrate makachev and win the rounds
just by staying outside I think you will
see kicks I think his speed his
quickness his overall up and down game
is going to be the the deciding factor
there I I think volcanovski beats on Via
decision